Speaker 1: Donald Trump joined an emergency prayer
call after his Mar a Lago speech, which came after
his arrest. He was joined by Michele Bachmann
and referred to our beautiful Christianity,
which he says I guess is under attack. Folks,
if Trump is turning to prayer and to God,
you know that he's scared. And that is indeed the
vibe I get here. The audio quality is, of course,
terrible, Trump says. We are losing our religion.
He says, That's me in the corner. No, okay, we're
losing our religion. And he's desperate, I guess,
for donations, money and prayer. Take a listen.
Speaker 5: We're being discriminated against
as a religion. We're being destroyed.
Speaker 1: By the way, I have not doctored the
audio to make it worse. It's genuinely this bad.
Speaker 5: Against us of faith and we
can't let that continue. I'm fighting
very hard for the people of our country,
but I'm very often very hard for people of
religious people. They believe in God, people.
They believe in faith. And it's an honor.
Speaker 1: To have so many. And that was a cough.
Coughing is really common on these prayer calls.
Speaker 5: My friends on the call, as you know,
we've. Going through a fake investigation. That's
what it is by radical people that I believe
actually have to heal our country. But we're
winning. We had a great day today, actually,
because it turned out to be a sham and turning
out to be that. And we have others down the line,
but we've been winning them for eight years now,
ever since we came down the golden escalator,
as they call it, at Trump Tower. But one
thing that I've always remained silent
on that is are these our religion And our
Christianity have beautiful Christianity and.
Speaker 1: And all too. Or maybe it was three
of the Corinthians that Trump knows.
Speaker 5: I think they remained and
they remained loyal to me or the people on this
line. Incredible people, the most respected people
I know. There can be no greater
calling than what you do. And yeah.
Speaker 1: One of the people on the line was Paula
White, the woman who was in that insane viral
religious videos where she's going and strike
and strike and strike and strike and strike,
and then she starts speaking in tongues. She
says hubba hubba, Atta or something like that.
That's one of the great people on the call
that Trump very much respects. Honestly,
he sounds more desperate for donations and
money than he does for prayer. And of course,
maybe the country wouldn't be less and less
religious over time if it weren't for the
fact that the people most loudly demanding
the return of public religion are absolute
lunatics. Wanting to completely break down any
kind of separation between church and state,
this wasn't even as bad as it got. Michele
Bachmann, the former Minnesota congresswoman,
was on the emergency prayer call and she
wants to beseech God or may or to beseech,
I never know who they want to beseech. But
anyway, here she she weighed in as well.
Speaker 5: Oh, God. Why do you declare
Donald J. Trump innocent? Oh, Father,
would you free Donald Trump from his trouble
and our troubles here in America? Oh, Lord,
would you have mercy on Donald J. Trump and
America? And would you hear the prayer tonight
from your people? Oh, Governor. Well, you people.
Speaker 2: Are in charge. Donald Trump's.
Speaker 1: Reputation right.
Speaker 5: Where you make your accusations
no more will you continue your right.
Speaker 1:
Okay. Okay. All right. And she just went on
from there. This is nuts, folks. This is totally
nuts. And this I think I don't know how many
donations this is going to generate for Trump,
but maybe it will generate some prayers and
we'll see sort of how effective those are